towards the end of Donald Trump's recent
trip to Asia and sort of in a couple of
days after coming back he was talking a
lot about how these three UCLA
basketball players that were freed by
China after being held on shoplifting
charges should really be thanking him
and Trump claims that he personally
asked the Chinese president for his help
freeing these three players but one of
the players parents levar Balls says you
know the truth is Trump didn't end up
having that much to do with the release
of players he might be right the truth
is that it's not actually clear how much
involvement influence or role to play
Donald Trump had in the release of these
players and my instinct is that the
father of one of the players might
actually know something about it
apparently the players didn't thank
Trump enough because now Trump is saying
that he should have let them sit in jail
in China tweeting quote now that the
three basketball players are out of
China and saved from years in jail Lavar
ball the father of Lee Angelo is
unaccepting of what I did for his son
and that shoplifting is no big deal I
should have left them in jail do you
understand what happened here Trump
wasn't flattered enough people didn't
heap enough praise onto Trump so the
result is he doesn't think he should
have worked to free American citizens
detained under unusual circumstances
abroad and even worse is that the
players did thank him right regardless
of whether Trump deserved the thanks or
not but one of the parents had the
audacity to say well I don't know how
much of a role Trump played and to Trump
that means I should have left them to
rot in jail the man has no values the
man has no personal philosophy he has no
guiding principles of right and wrong
the values of Trump are greed and self
aggrandizement period and this along
with so much else really proves it can
anybody imagine I mean just think hard
for a second can you imagine Bill
Clinton doing this he went to North
Korea merely to secure the release of
two detained journalists can you imagine
afterwards saying I should have left
there to rot in prison because they
didn't thank me enough can you imagine
Barack Obama or even George W Bush for
that matter doing something like this
you can't because this is a unique and
singular kind of degeneracy and
indecency from President Donald Trump a
person that is well adjusted and sort of
connected to the real world and regular
people would realize hey I'm the
president of the United States I'm in a
position to help and it's my duty to
help people if I can but for Trump it's
about how much praise will I get who
will kiss my feet for having done it and
it's a real embarrassment the President
of the United States suggesting that
maybe he should have proactively decided
not to help American citizens being
detained abroad merely because one of
their parents didn't praise him the way
he wanted to be praised there actually
were days in the United States when a
president of either party might say
something like this and he would
immediately be crushed by elected
officials from both the Democratic in
the Republican Party that doesn't seem
to be the case right now and I know
we're not supposed to diagnose at a
distance but when it comes to
personality disorders there's actually a
lot that you can glean through the media
unless you believe Trump is deliberately
acting right playing some kind of a
character through the media we can
examine whether Trump has the markers of
narcissistic personality disorder which
is really not something you want in a
president and he has every single one of
the markers according to the Mayo Clinic
the markers of a narcissistic
personality disorder suffer include
having an exaggerated sense of
self-importance check having a sense of
entitlement and requiring constant
excessive admiration twice a day
propaganda briefings I think is an
example of that expect to be recognized
as superior even without achievements
that warranted Trump to a tee
exaggeration of achievements and talents
I was uh i I'm brilliant I did
incredibly at Wharton I'm just as such a
smart guy I did better than everybody
else being preoccupied with fantasies
about success power brilliance beauty or
the perfect mate don't think I need to
elaborate on that one
believing that they
superior and can only associate with
equally special people I'm going to put
the best people around me I work with
the best people I hire the best people
monopolizing conversations and
belittling or looking down on people
they perceive as inferior well yeah
expecting special favors and
unquestioning compliance with their
expectations taking advantage of others
to get what they want and inability or
unwillingness to recognize the needs and
feelings of others being envious of
others and believing others envy them
behaving in an arrogant or haughty
manner coming across as conceited
boastful and pretentious and insisting
on having the best of everything
for instance the best car or office Pat
isn't this written as if it's a
personality description of Trump not of
someone with narcissistic personality
disorders it fits him to a tee yeah it
makes me wonder if this was an edited
list or if this was the entire thing I
wondered because I saw this list
floating around I said I wonder if only
the items that match Trump have been
hand-picked so I went to a source I went
straight to the Mayo Clinic it's the
full list every single item on the list
of signs of narcissistic personality
disorder matched Trump to a tee and that
is not exactly a condition you want
people who are in such a position of
power suffering from will take a break
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show support for today's episode
of the David Pakman show comes from
health IQ health IQ believes that the
best way to improve the health of the
world is to celebrate the health
conscious through social and financial
rewards so what they do is use science
and data to secure lower rates on life
insurance for health-conscious people
including runners cyclists strength
trainers vegans much too producer Pat's
delight and more 56% of health IQ
customers save between four and thirty
three percent on their life insurance
these savings are exclusive to health IQ
it's like saving money for being a good
driver on your car insurance health IQ
gets you lower rates on life insurance
for leading a health-conscious lifestyle
after all physically active people have
a 34% lower risk of all
cause mortality 56 percent lower risk of
heart disease and 22 percent decrease in
cancer mortality compared to people who
remain inactive to see if you qualify
get your free quote today at health
iq.com slash Pakman that's health iq.com
slash PA k ma n to get your free quote